all right we are now live for the
December ama that's asked me anything
session for 2019 this is the last one of
the year
well I'm waiting for people to show up
and get questions up there for me I'm
going to just tell you a little bit
about how the month is turning out so
I've got my daughter here in Milwaukee
she just did in in and out interviews
auditions at University of Wisconsin
Milwaukee and we went to the library and
to the museum just a few minutes ago we
just got back so it's beautiful day out
here cold though in Milwaukee and what
else have we got going on well I'm
driving her back down tomorrow got the
AMA of course today and a few other
things then we're heading over to
Milwaukee Institute of Art design for
their Christmas sale so I could see what
some of my students have been doing as
far as their their arts and crafts and
maybe find some decent Christmas
presents for everyone alright
so we've already got a question from
Linden nice to see you here Linden have
any philosophers talked about
procrastination either causes solutions
or what it reveals about humanity you
know I I don't know that anyone except
for very recent contemporary
philosophers and I don't know any of the
ones who did it recently have talked
about procrastination by that name
because it's I think it's a fairly
recent word but there's there's people
who have talked about the concept I mean
it definitely fits into the earlier
discussions
starting with with vague respond to kiss
and John Cassian and then like moving
into the seven deadly sins area of the
eight capital vices because it ties in
with Acadia or you know sometimes it's
called the noonday devil which is this
this sort of occupying oneself with
stuff that's
it's in the not in the purview of what
one's supposed to be doing so you know
John Cassian for example talks about
monks who instead of like doing the
stuff in their cell and saying their
prayers and all that they're like I
think I better go find out what father
John is up to I think he needs some help
over there so there's there's
discussions of that in that vein and
that gets rolled into sloth usually we
think of sloths is kind of laziness but
procrastination isn't laziness as such
it's more a doing everything else other
than what you're supposed to be doing
and I think that a lot of what other
philosophers have to say about fear or
anxiety could fit in with that or pain
or disappointment so those would be
those areas I would I would take a look
at lurid awesome rites what is humanity
going through in the context of
Nietzsche's Nietzsche as everyone's
starting to reevaluate values and as the
Internet and our access to information
speeding this up I wouldn't say that
most people are actually really
weighting values in that sense most
people are actually whether they they're
politically or liberal or conservative
are actually quite conservative they're
not they're not trying to change things
in that sense grab the cord that the cat
just knocked out I would say that that
you know what Nietzsche has in mind is
not being done by most people including
most people who fancy themselves
Nietzsche ins you know and think that
they're the uber manager you know they
think that nature can be harnessed or
something because here's so much against
any sort of movement politics including
you know social and cultural movements
that he would say most people today are
still within the orbit of dispositions
that are ultimately feeding into niall
ism but but trying to escape niall ism
so all right um let's see
Dmitri considering your speculative
fiction series when you might cover JG
Ballard do you see any issues with
technology in the postmodern age so I
mean going by the poll results were
probably got to be covering Ballard but
that question is so vague I don't know
what to make of it issues with
technology in the postmodern age I mean
there's lots of issues with technology
but there's lots of issues with
technology in every age because to be
human is to use technology so maybe you
could ask something a bit more specific
Bruno what do you think of Alfred North
Whitehead what do you think about his
process philosophy
I actually was very into Whitehead when
I was an undergraduate read my way
through process and reality probably
didn't understand everything that I was
reading probably only understood half of
it but I got enough to actually like
it's enough Amica I got enough to
actually sort of see his vision the dog
is growling at the cat because she
thinks the cat's gonna steal her food or
something
I haven't even run for a long time so I
am not all that qualified to say much
about Whitehead I will say I'm you know
read some of his other books and I enjoy
reading that stuff but process and
reality that's that's something that I
should get back to and read my way
through again it's just a matter of
finding the time if you're asking
whether it's worth spending time reading
Alfred North Whitehead I would say
definitely he's he's very interesting
he's got some some you know interesting
perspectives that he's bringing to the
table and he doesn't fit neatly into the
sort of narrative that we tell about
philosophy so he could be quite quite
good to check out all right Jimmy
Neutron ways in that Whitehead was retro
actively refuted by grinning and
Parmenides I definitely don't think
that's the case
to tecnique do you think you'll make
videos on Spinoza I mean it may be
eventually hopefully I'll make videos on
everybody
Spinoza is not among my priorities
because I don't typically teach Spinoza
in classes people ask me about that
anybody is free if they want to to
Commission me to make videos on a
quicker timetable but then you actually
have to pay for it so people are always
asking you know what about Schopenhauer
you know don't you like him yeah it's
not about whether I find somebody
interesting it's about mostly whether
it's fitting into the resources that I
need from my classes or whether I see I
mean Spinoza is interesting I would I'd
be much more likely to shoot videos on
Pascal who I think is in some respects
more insightful than Spinoza then I
would on Spinoza so it probably worked
my way through the pass A's I true
Spinoza before I'd shoot Maul brush but
I'd probably shoot live notes before I
shoot Spinoza so all right Anthony Fikri
do you have any thoughts on Charles
Taylor sources of the self and his work
in general Taylor fits into that sort of
spectrum of philosophers like Alistair
McIntyre who are doing really sort of
big picture what's been going on what
changed sort of stuff I'm not as
interested in Taylor as I am in
MacIntyre but I see them as within the
same sort of overall project sources of
the self it's definitely a book that you
should you should get and read your way
through it's it's you know another
person who is doing a similar project
but isn't in the same camp you might say
is Jurgen Habermas right with this
philosophical discourse of modernity or
you know another good book in that sear
Shinae wins the invention of autonomy
which unfortunately doesn't doesn't very
doesn't do a very good job of mentioning
women philosophers but but otherwise is
a pretty interesting sort of history of
ideas thing so that's where I see Taylor
fitting in well
the questions works in general you know
he's certainly somebody who's important
and worth reading I have limited time so
I don't think I'm probably gonna go back
to tailor and spend much time on them
whereas with you know McIntyre Chris
Gill or Julia on us or people like that
I'm I definitely know it's worth my time
to go back because it fits in more with
the projects that I have but you can
certainly read them I bet you can find
sources of the self at a used bookstore
very easily um let's see here I just
question here we go well there's a lot
of questions now
Lowell asks would you ever consider
doing any videos on Platonists or any
neoplatonist I have done videos on
neoplatonist Augustine and Louie theus
but yeah I mean more seriously adding
anybody in that like you know strict
neoplatonist thing like porphyry yeah
I'd certainly do that that's that's a
gap I don't teach them in my classes so
there's there's no real call for me to
churn out videos right away because
there's no need and the part of my
students but I find them very
interesting and worth reading so you
know I'm right now doing a lot of stuff
on simply kiyose in his commentary on
epic to use epictetus is an ingredient
so you know down the line perhaps
Nicolas asks a new to philosophy and
interest in epistemology what are some
essential reads on steel Manning
scepticism and on arguments against that
I don't know you know that sounds like a
like a question for Google or for other
people I I don't spend a lot of time I
mean steel Manning is a relatively new
term an idea so you could probably find
more stuff out there on blog sites then
you're gonna find particularly good
books but you know any any decent
how did you argumentation book I'll
probably get you started with that sort
of thing there you know there aren't any
sources that I particularly recommend
for that and skepticism that covers an
entire range of things I don't know what
you mean it's got skepticism about
social realities or moral realities or
about the world in general I mean you
could read the skeptics like sexist
empirica sore you know read the first
part of Descartes but then read the rest
of de cartes meditations but it's not
really not really my my area steel
Manning is something that we were doing
in the past we just didn't congratulate
ourselves on calling it steel Manning it
was called the principle of charity
right so yeah I'm not really into a lot
of those those those those things
Hayden LaBrie I'm trying to get into
victims dying the issue of language do
you think language limits human reason
it depends on you have to make a
distinction there it depends on what you
mean by limits human reason
if you mean limits the possibilities for
human reason for the entire human race
yes in the sense that you always do have
to think in a language and so there's
always going to be some determinacy but
we have multiple languages as human
beings and so we also know that there's
differences between languages and we can
to some degree overcome those most
individual human beings are definitely
going to be limited in their thinking
processes by their language and usually
without realizing it but that doesn't
mean that we're always like stuck in our
own like hermetic bubble you know that
we have our own form of life and it's
it's radically in commenced trouble with
somebody else's form of life the way
some people interpreting it can shine
did here's a question from CS what do I
think about who Cyril was originally
inspired by Descartes is there such a
thing as first philosophy really so you
got a couple different questions there
let's talk about coaster oils
inspiration by Descartes I suppose
people think so because of the Cartesian
meditations right but who strolls also
means deeply influenced by human on the
issue of association of ideas and he's
very much in conversation with the neo
conscience of his time so I would say no
is he's not primarily or originally
influenced by Descartes as a matter of
fact one of the people who he is working
off of Brunt
Bren Brentano is a neo scholastic who's
trainer you know resuscitate Aristotle
so hoofer like meant most other
philosophers is drawing upon multiple
sources and he's got his own particular
sets of interests that he's bringing to
it what do I think about his role I
think whose role is one of the most
boring people to read and I you know and
I even like have people read Jeremy
Bentham and he's pretty dry too but he's
worth reading it's it's an exercise you
probably should go through at some time
or another I'll mention that whose role
scholars are often kind of an
interesting Bunch
in the sense of interesting that they
had they definitely have their stick
they are very nerdy in general and tend
to be a lot like a certain style of
old-school analytics but you know
they're decent people and I've worked
with quite a few of them I actually
wrote my master's thesis on his role and
the paths of synthesis lectures that
were recently at that time being
translated by Toni Steinbach I don't
find whistle interesting enough to
really draw upon very much when it comes
to phenomenology I'm much more
interested in people like Marcel and
Heidegger and the Schaller among the
early phenomenologist Edith Stein as
well Marie Kondo blown dal who's doing
something very similar to phenomenology
and Barrett stone of course who's doing
something similar with his essay on
immediate Gibbons of consciousness but
you know whose role is worth reading now
is there such a thing as first
philosophy it depends on what
philosopher you ask because you know
what's recommended as first philosophy
is the thing that's
like foundational for everything else so
a lot of the phenomenologist regarded
phenomenology is like supplying a first
philosophy the people who got into
semiotic Stearn that into first
philosophy the people who are doing you
know even though they would deny this
who were doing like ordinary language
analysis and the analytic movement we're
doing that essentially his first
philosophy as well
cons critiques are supposed to supply a
certain kind of first philosophy levy
Nass talks about ethics his first
philosophy I'm actually much more
inclined to the notion of ethics and the
study of values is being closer to the
core of things and I would say there I'm
in agreement with Schaller von
Hildebrand
and Marcel and people like that but is
there really a first philosophy in any
methodological sense where you have to
begin with that I don't think so
there's a lot of ways of doing
philosophy and you know I won't say that
they're all equally legitimate or
anything like that but some you know
there's certainly a pluralism possible I
would say all right let's see what do we
get here I'm duel is the history of all
hitherto existing society the history of
class struggles asking for a friend
if you mean in the reductive sense as
only being history of class struggles
then definitely no if you mean does it
and does it include an encompass and and
you know is it useful to look at class
struggles yes
class and economics is certainly a vital
domain of human existence but I don't
you know I don't think we should reduce
it like that all right Bob Jackson
writes I'm suffering serious health
problems because of my illness is it
justified to kill yourself in life
becomes worse every day and you will die
soon you know there's different points
of view on that
the Stoics for example thought that if
things become unendurable that one you
know one could legitimately leave but
that a lot of people were using that as
a pretext
to simply try to escape things if it
becomes worse and worse everyday and you
have no no prognosis of things ever
becoming better if you are going to die
soon then it seems like in some respects
it's less of an issue than knowing that
you're gonna linger on for years and
years because if you are gonna die soon
something else is determining that
deciding that for you so if you're
asking like is it better to die a week
before one would die but but you know
usually the questions are things like
I'm gonna die soon but I want to avoid
the horrible pain that's going to come
with that I mean if you're asking what
my personal view is I think in a case
like the latter that it would be morally
legitimate to do that
and many people indeed do you know do
that the other thing to keep in mind - I
would say and I don't know I don't know
your situation is you have to think
about the people that you're leaving
behind as well and how what you do is
going to affect them in some cases I
think for some people ending one's life
sooner would be a relief for those who
are involved with them right or taking
on responsibilities with them in other
cases it would be viewed as a sort of
betrayal or a abandonment so these are
these are not things that there's easy
answers for I I do have some clients and
I've had clients in the past who are
faced with these sorts of issues in in
my philosophical counseling clients so
alright Lyndon asks even though I'm not
a hag Elian how useful do I find his
ideas as an intellectual tool in making
sense of the world in general um
somewhat useful I can usually tell that
at different points in time more than
others and it's I mean I'm not a galley
in the sense that I think that Hegel had
the blueprint for everything and made
sense out of everything so and I think
the end of history stuff is nonsense too
but you can recognize when you've been
studying his work for a while you can
recognize certain dynamics as kind of
common all right and that's very helpful
I will say this too well this is going
to seem like a bit of a rant the
interpretation of Hegel that takes the
master-slave dialectic is absolutely
centrally important is complete nonsense
mieka I got the dog and the cat raising
trouble with each other and cat is
trying to crawl up on top of the dog
believe it or not the dogs not not
interested in this being one-tenth her
size crawling on her so I should
probably come over here by me in a
moment so in any case
yeah Hegel can be can be very helpful
and useful here comes a cat take a look
say there there she is getting getting
into trouble but you know the
master-slave dialectic there's also
probably the second most commonly
referenced thing is the beautiful soul
which is part of the the morality
section and that's that's good to check
out but again you got to be really
careful in identifying these gestalt you
know of consciousness everywhere there's
another one from CS how does one avoid
always learning and never being able to
arrive at a knowledge of the truth just
settle on Aristotle as a foundation well
I mean I don't think it's a problem to
always be learning I mean even if you
have a foundation you're a finite being
and we don't know much of anything so
you should always be learning constantly
you should be learning about the the
beings around you and you know so you
might say entering into their lives more
and more deeply all the time so it's not
always learning that's the problem it's
I think the thing that you're worried
about more is like whether
that learning is replacing other
learning whether you're ever gonna like
get to the bottom of things right and
why would you settle on Aristotle as a
foundation Aristotle's works are
incredibly under determined and written
in you know a time and culture two
millennia ago why wouldn't you like draw
upon a variety of different thinkers why
not be an eclectic like Cicero was or
like I am or what you know James would
call a pluralist I mean huh I like
Aristotle quite a bit but I wouldn't
want to try to use his categories in
metaphysics let alone his totally
outdated biology as the basis for
understanding this amazing universe that
we're in or the very interesting things
that we human beings are so that's
that's as good of an answer I think as I
can provide about that Bruno any
favorite cultures in history against the
ancient Greek and Roman for their
philosophy but any others so you know do
another little rant here there is no
such thing as Greek or Roman culture you
know that's all fabricated [ __ ]
later on by people who wanted to use
that to sort of appropriate it and
justify how cool they were because they
were they're bringing at in if you if
you actually study ancient Greece and
its connections with these all these
other places you come to realize there
isn't one single culture there is like
all these different fragments of things
connected with each other in different
ways and it's the same thing for Rome
and it's the same thing for Persia and
it's the same thing for Egypt or China
or any of these India there's such an
interesting melange and there's all
these transfers going on so you know do
I have a favorite culture I don't I
would you know I would love if we could
get away from trying to appropriate
cultures the way that people in the past
did with these artificial constructs
that we call races as well it's such
sloppy
ways of arranging and valuing things so
you know it's it there's better ways of
doing it I don't I don't usually think
of these these terms you know like I'm
not thinking I'm studying Aristotle cuz
he's a Greek and Greek so really Greek
culture is really important I'm studying
Aaron's level cuz there's interesting
ideas there and if I'd happen to get
those interesting ideas from an Indian
philosopher or Chinese philosopher had I
read Sanskrit or
classical Chinese I'd be just as happy
getting them from from that because it's
the ideas that I'm really much more
interested in rather than trying to hold
on to culture sama sometimes philosophy
if it can shine and Heidegger looked so
similar but their style looks so
different if there is could you explain
similarities between them so Alistair
McIntyre in a famous interview that was
carried out in in the journal Kinesis
said that he thought that Heidegger was
an important philosopher mainly because
Heidegger gotten so many things wrong
and so many people were following him
and mikan-chan was an important
philosopher in a different way and I
would actually I would reverse it I
actually think that hiding out waste way
more stuff right and went way deeper in
his examinations of things than MIT
constrained it Vidkun shed circled
around stuff and came up with some cool
ideas but he really impoverished himself
by not doing enough reading and not
doing enough deep engagement with the
people that he talks about I mean people
do like well you're definitely read
Augustine you read a little bit of
Augustine but he doesn't seem to have
like thought through very much of
Augustine because he's got this you know
he got enough to get the Augustinian
picture of language and that was it I
think that that you know the big
contingent notion of language game and
some of the things that he's he's doing
in philosophical investigations remarks
on the foundations of mathematics
uncertainty these later works are really
worth thinking about and they can they
can take you a little bit further than
Heidegger does on some things
but Heidegger had the benefit of like
really reading Aristotle and thinking
about Aristotle really reading Plato and
thinking about Plato you know of course
he's deficient when it comes to the
Hellenistic philosophers but even like
you know really thinking through
Descartes and content stuff like that
that gave him a incredible advantage so
now you know they are doing something
kind of similar and that they're anti
foundationalist but so are so many
others
that's why Richard Rorty in his the
mirror of nature could say that he's
drawing on Vidkun Stein from the
analytic tradition Heidegger from the
Continental tradition and John Dewey
from the American tradition there's so
many others that they could have drawn
on as well but you know that those were
the correlations he's making so alright
snow people often praise the love of
learning but how does one actually
foster one's love of learning are there
interesting philosophers who wrote about
it I suppose there must be but I I you
know I mean Plato talks about it in the
Republic doesn't he how one Foster's
that but I think there's no like recipe
for it you're talking in a way about
what we often call second-order desires
a love of learning is a desire for
learning being oriented towards learning
and you could like maybe like that to a
certain extent but but not as much as
you would like to do or you struggle
because you don't you don't get as much
effectively out of learning you don't
get as much enjoyment as you'd like and
you'd like that to be different so there
the good news is yeah one way you can
change that is by doing more and more of
it because a lot of a lot of learning is
and this is one thing where I think that
the the Aristotle and the interpreters
of Aristotle got something right
intellectual excellences are habits they
have not habits in the sense of like not
true in your fingernails or things like
that they are these complexes that
build up and they're built up through
action after action after action
thinking is an action choosing to think
about something as an action choosing to
study something is in the action so
doing that over and over again builds up
these these complexes that we call a
habitus or a hexxus in greek so that
that is part of it
I'm sure there's probably all sorts of
literature out there about that but I
don't I don't know too much about that
so alright Guillaume what is the
Philosopher's Stone
there was a legendary thing that would
turn lead into gold so not anything
really connected with philosophy in the
sense that we talk about today just go
Petter let's see Chloe asks would I be
able to shed some light on my Plato in
the Republic finds it necessary to prove
the analogy between the city and the
soul exists he doesn't prove an analogy
between the city and the soul exists he
sets out an analogy and then he he
discusses it I don't know that he proves
anything there I'm not sure where that's
coming from that that notion of proof
why is it important he tells you right
there in the thing it's too hard to look
at the soul by itself maybe if we look
at something bigger he's got that
analogy of the letters right we look at
something with with smaller letters and
bigger letters we might more easily be
able to read them Alexandre what's your
thoughts on Friedrich Hayek's political
philosophy have you read any political
works I mean I read Hayek a long time
ago but not enough to be able to say
much about it other than I don't find
him particularly interesting and you
know I often judge judge philosophers
when I don't know the time to do so
based on the people I see recommending
him and you know I don't see a lot of
print see a lot of people who I respect
intellectually who are like super into
Hayek
and the people who are into Hayek seem
to be like really into Hayek you know
every once in awhile I get like oh you
do look at this from a proxy illogical
perspective and I'm like oh my god one
of those again so I'm probably
disappointing you in that respect Bruno
do I recommend the writings of any
particular historian for what I mean
for history in general for I mean it
would depend on what particular thing
you're asking about and and probably not
I mean I'm not a historiography so
alright titus and dronicus who in your
opinion is the greatest or most
important American philosopher so they
had an interesting one in terms of
importance like influence on things I
would say John Dewey definitely is the
most important in that sense but I don't
like to read Dewey because I don't I
don't think he's a very good writer so
very unclear at points and I don't agree
with a lot of his sort of assessments
and assumptions I would say the greatest
American philosopher that you know from
classical American philosophy is Josiah
Royce I well you know I also do like
person James but I'd probably give Royce
the edge on them so all right Artie
whitby who created the correspondence of
theory of truth was a Socrates Plato
Aristotle none of them I mean we didn't
start talking in terms of correspondence
theory of truth until like the 19th
century I think so yep gum bring her in
the other room I you know there's this
whole notion of like rereading this
stuff backwards into people is bad
history of ideas and it's usually done
for the purpose of like right now
correspondence theory of truth because
of babbu gaussians
wrongheaded article that that's trying
to blow it up into like a whole way of
being you know sometimes they'll
substitute the word realism for that
that's all nonsense that's that's crappy
history of ideas you know you can see
Plato and Aristotle talking about things
that we nowadays call correspondence
theory of truth you can also find
Aristotle talking about truth in other
ways so it's really important not to try
to like assume some philosophical
legitimacy by tying these things and in
with these people I mean the notion that
that in some cases of truth truth in in
language or thought would be a
resemblance or correspondence between
what is in the mind or in language and
what is actually in the world there is
no originator of that that's been around
her for a long time and that's one
notion of truth and truth also in the
sense of you know what's later called
the pragmatic theory of truth there was
later called the the coherence theory of
truth you can find that in ancient
philosophy as well so it's kind of a
non-starter as a question here's another
one
Western man are you more inclined
towards idealism or empiricism after
your lifetime of studies I'm not
inclined towards any isms
they're almost always turn out to be too
reductive to be of any use to me I I
want to understand things adequately and
that's just not possible you know buying
into those sorts of things it's kind of
cool that these big programs are no
longer dominating the philosophical
scheme and we can get back to like
actually doing philosophy Aarti whitby
wedded Plato change color Kalos guy got
those two Agatha's case so flows I don't
know I mean reference the the text in
which he does that again that sounds
like something that's coming out of
somebody's history of ideas book
Lia are you are you gonna do more of
Senecas letters I am indeed because I
need them for my classes these core
concept videos I'm typically doing for
my students in my classes and then
they're there for the rest of the world
as well so I'll certainly be doing that
aunty gaya what are some contemporary
philosophical fiction writers you would
recommend well one that's funny that you
would ask that because this coming week
I'll be talking about one of them whose
books I've read my way through over the
last month and a half we're finishing up
the worlds of speculative fiction series
and I'll be talking about our Scott
Walker who was not even like on my radar
at all until he got voted in and the
last year's vote for who would be the
big names for the last three sessions
and I read his prints of nothing series
which is three books and then I read his
aspect Emperor series which is the the
next four books in the second Apocalypse
arc it's incredibly philosophical it's
very dark you should think of sort of
like j.r.r tolkien meets george RR
martin meet george RR martin meets frank
herbert and a couple other things mixed
in as well and that's that's what you've
got there and so that's quite good you
can never go wrong with Philip dick very
philosophical writer a lot of his
characters are like talking philosophy
in their their discourses and making
interesting things out of them and
there's there's plenty others as well
you know I would say one of the things
about speculative fiction is it offers
you the opportunity to work in a broad
canvas with with ideas so you know CJ
Chara as somebody who's doing that in
her Alliance Union universe
there's many others that we could we
could talk about as well
Nathan Packard can you explain
Nietzsche's ideas on causality I'm not
sure which ideas you mean maybe you're
talking about his notion that is
expressed at various points in his work
that we have high pasta ties
cause-and-effect into you know thinking
that there really is a thing called
croisé and effect and you know that's
something we can rely upon like like why
like regularity he thinks that the
universe doesn't really operate in that
way that a lot of it is this dynamism of
the will but that's not to say that some
things don't work in that way so Assad
do I think when studying philosophy some
branches must be studied before others
maybe it depends on who you're studying
it with I guess depends on what kind of
student you are if you're asking me the
question of is a program necessary where
like you do logic before everything else
or you do metaphysics and you like get
that completely out of the way before
anything else no because you're gonna
read and reread and reread doing
philosophy is a continual process of
going back and forth and back and forth
and back and forth any philosophical
texts that you want to actually
understand expect to read it at least 10
times and some of those readings should
not be right after the previous reading
it should be after you've read somebody
else and thought about some other things
so no there isn't any there isn't any
like absolute sequence or program that
you would need to do Artie would
be--would Plato and Aristotle think of
the stoic anti intellectual anti
knowledge position that you should not
seek externals knowledge as an external
and therefore you should not seek
knowledge well that's a complete
distortion of stoic doctrine so I'm not
even going to bother with that
it's a non-starter Kiran have you
noticed that Heidegger is making a
resurgence as a result of the climate
crisis that pushes from more technology
in the form of wind farms solar power
tidal power etc I think that has
absolutely nothing to do with Heidegger
at all
Heidegger has been a perennial interest
in continental circles there are a few
analytics were interested in Heidegger
I mean yet the place for my wife is
still working on her dissertation
European graduate school Heidegger is
basically the guy you start with so you
know Heidegger is is a great thinker
like most great thinkers has some
interesting contributions to make also
has some big blind spots but he's not
making I don't see Heidegger making a
big comeback right now I think there's
been a continual interest in him Liberty
Ellis we're what do I think of Ludwig
von Mises not too much not somebody I
spend time on raid what I think of mocs
Turner's philosophy 'no similarities to
nietzsche i think there are similarities
to nietzsche I likes Turner he's an
interesting figure I will be doing some
videos on him because I'm expanding my
discussions of egoism for my ethics
classes that I'm teaching this this
coming semester so you know I'll be
doing some things on the classic work of
his really the only work of his that
anyone I think reads the ego and its own
there's another translation of it out
there the unique in its property right
so interesting stuff I think that his
union of egoist as a complete
non-starter that that would never
actually work and but he doesn't you
know he's fun he's fun to read and talk
about underdog tactics to talk about my
therapy practice what is my treatment
approach I don't have a therapy practice
because therapy is medical I have a
philosophical counseling practice
and that's more of a coaching focus I
there is no one single modality that I
do sometimes I suggest readings and we
discuss them we talked about how they
apply to the person's life sometimes we
look at the ways in which people are
having you know emotions arise for them
particularly anger and anxiety in
particular situations and we're
examining the thought processes that go
into them and figuring out what we could
do to try to head those off a lot of
reframing exercises I draw upon you know
a lot of different philosophical
approaches since people have been
discussing these issues for several
thousand years now but I also draw upon
other approaches as well I mean it
depends on who the client is and what
they're looking for a lot of what we do
is quite dialogical you know back and
forth them some of it is is essentially
business coaching you know our executive
coaching helping people figure out where
they want to go with their careers how
to make their value systems actually
less contradictory so that they're not
living these compartmentalized lives
that's that's pretty much it
Sisyphus can I explain Hegel's
determinate negation negation of
negation with something being concrete
as a result I mean that's you know a
formula but without actually focusing on
a particular dynamic that's about is
that's about as close to the phenomena
as you can get I think copper King what
is wickedness of a devil I don't know
probably wit you know general wickedness
carried out by a being lacking a
physical body and therefore not
encumbered by all the things that we are
I don't know I don't know what the
reference point for that is Joshua did
the Christian existentialist influence
my current theological beliefs if you
happen to four would you talk a bit
about your book so two totally different
questions there yeah I mean the
Christian existentialist have have
influenced
my my current current theological
beliefs I mean I don't know that I have
theological beliefs
I have practices and I have you know
sort of a framework I said this so many
times and I'll say it again the writers
who I find particularly interesting when
it comes to religion are not the ones
for whom religion solved any of their
problems
it's the ones where it gave them a
greater view on the universe on
themselves on other human beings and on
whatever it is that we call the divine
and it made things incredibly more
complicated and contradictory in the
process so you know I don't like
apologetics I find apologetics it's
boring and you know rigid and I like
people who face up to how complicated a
mess this this thing is and think that
religion provides some sort of insights
into that so Kierkegaard you know plays
a role in my thought as does chest'
stuff as does blown-down as does Pascal
all these people that sometimes get
called Christian existentialist I mean
chest office is Jewish but he he writes
a lot about the New Testament as well
now my book so my book is a set of
translations come on Piku set of
translations with a about a hundred page
historical introduction and a twenty a
25 page chronological bibliography and
it's about the Christian philosophy
debates of the 1930s which involved
about 50 different francophone
philosophers it got started originally
with some discussions between at the
society across des des filosophy between
ATMs you'll saw in Jack more ten on one
side although there was already a letter
from Blondell that was appended to it
so yeah them on one side and then breaky
air and runs rig on the rationalists
side and there were actually some some
other letters from some other thinkers
as well that were added to the original
thing that didn't make it into the
translation because the associate a
trois use the philosophy wouldn't allow
me to to add that into the book but then
there's all these other interventions
that were quite important and I would
say that only even after my translation
only about maybe a fifth of the
literature from the debate has actually
been translated so there's quite a bit
more to do I just haven't had the time
to follow up with all of that myself so
alright um spod that did I describe I
subscribe to the notion there is an end
of history that history is a process of
the improvement of mankind no I think
that to begin with there isn't a process
of history there's all sorts of
histories interweaving with each other
and I think that part of what's going on
is we also decide what kind of history
we want to be continuing on through so
right now we're posed with you know like
one of the fundamental questions of our
time is are we gonna get our [ __ ]
together enough politically so that we
can actually address some of the things
of otherwise destroy the human race you
know when we whether whether we you know
climate change proceeds in exactly the
way that the models predict we're using
up a lot of resources polluting a lot of
stuff and we're not going to make it out
to the Stars anytime you know soon
enough to do much about that so this is
the the world we've got and if we can't
decide as a species to quit screwing
things up we're screwed and history
becomes a moot point at that point
because it'll be an alien civilization
with their archaeologists figuring out
what
going on here you know and there's other
there's other things that are equally
pressing I mean all it would take is one
massive pandemic to really derail the
civilization that we live in which is so
incredibly dependent on all these
massive networks maintaining themselves
so you know those are the sort of things
that we're gonna have to face up to
there is no automatic guaranteed we're
gonna we're gonna deal with these things
right and there isn't I mean there could
be some sort of divine intervention
where you know whatever the divine is
comes in just open it up and you know
fixes everything but that is so
incredibly improbable
and quite frankly I don't I don't think
that a adjust God would come in and do
that you know or if they did they'd make
all the people who come in screw things
up pay for what they've been doing so no
I don't think there's any sort of
automatic advance in history I mean look
at in our own time
I'm just think about race relations you
know people got a so ticked off about
there being a black president and you
know there's this temporary enthusiasm
of the post-racial America that we swung
back into some of the worst kinds of
racism and atavism that are that are now
becoming normalized you know definitely
making a regress in terms of those sorts
of things although they probably
wouldn't see it as a regress the people
who are in favor of that they'd see it
as progress tearing the the you know
false liberalism down or something like
that but
yeah so that's probably enough on that
Dimitri okay my more specific question
you see any merit and the so-called
event of the melding of the sexual and
the technological and postmodern art eg
Ballard the alien series etc do I see
any merit yeah I think that that art is
interesting art I don't think it's an
event I think it's it's you could say
it's a whole bunch of events that are
strung together like a network into a
process
I mean I'll have to read Ballard I read
I read crash years ago was not impressed
but then again I'm not impressed by a
lot of these these you know we didn't
call them postmodern but these late
modern authors that that were the
darlings of the 80s and 90s and early
2000s but you know gonna be reading him
this year so we'll see what I make of
them then George a my Geiger that's
interesting work so yeah Nils crayon a
teacher of mine argues for rhetoric as
first philosophy as it all started there
anyone can argue for anything good for
your teacher I mean as it all started
there it all started with rhetoric the
schools of rhetoric arose later than the
first philosophers as we know but both
of them were later than the Homeric
bards so maybe we should say that's
first philosophy you know or I don't
know cave painting should be whatever
started there so not not a very useful
not a very useful criterion I think
Jocko picked how did I become such a
good rhetoric is there anything special
we should know oh you're asking how I
became a good rhetorician or became good
at presenting a lot of it is through
repetition doing lots and lots and lots
of it I mean I've been teaching since
1998 I think and I've been doing public
speaking since I mean my first paid
public speaking gig was 2008 but I was
doing public speaking before that as
well and you know I've studied classical
rhetoric and I you know read a lot and I
pay attention to what people seem to
respond to and what people don't and
rhetoric you know is in part
attentiveness to your audience that's
that central to it so that would be
there'd be good Thomas asks any good
books on rhetoric I mean Aristotle's
rhetoric okay
Plato discusses rhetoric in different
places including the phaedra swear he so
it's not the possibility of a good
rhetoric there's a whole classical
tradition of paying attention to
rhetoric that flows through you know
Cicero and quintillion and people like
Augustine and then you know there's cool
stuff in the present like well late you
know the 20th century like kind Pearlman
and ol bricks
Pig I don't remember how the name is
pronounced then the new rhetoric or
there's lots of great studies out there
it's kind of Burke is kind of cool
so you know there's lots and lots you
could read all right crazy [ __ ] I ever
wanted to write your own philosophy
rather than teach others I don't see
that as a dichotomy every time that I am
teaching other people's philosophy and
doing it well I'm doing it I'm the one
who's giving voice to it's sort of like
translating you know this is this is we
place way too much stress on originality
I mean I have insights every once in a
while that I occasionally will write
down but they're usually going to be
indebted to somebody else so that's
that's cool that's perfectly fine by me
because
need to try to you know do my own system
or do something original
I think originality is extremely
overrated all right Lenny penny any
advice for someone who's twenty-five and
doesn't really know what to do with his
life what's the right way to orient in
his life yeah do something and maybe
you'll find out that that's the thing
that you actually like and if you don't
then you can do something else but you
don't have to like figure out once and
for all what you're going to be because
we're not medieval you know well I mean
if you are medieval peasant kids to stay
in medieval peasant right you're not in
some absolutely job stratified thing
where you you can't do something
different as a matter of fact whatever
the whatever career track you pick you
should probably expect that you won't
get to remain it the rest of your life
right so you know you should figure out
what you actually value and start
working with it and sometimes it'll have
to be on your off time you know not
necessarily everything that you like
will get you paid and allow you to
maintain yourself and potentially a
household and family but you can you can
still do it I was just talking with my
daughter about the fact that I used to
do watercolors and there's really no
reason why I can't keep doing watercolor
I don't know why I stopped doing it
other than I got so busy maybe I'll
start doing it again in the new year you
know so let's see here
tea Gaines to what extent is Heidegger's
definition of metaphysics differ from
conventional metaphysics I don't know
what you mean by conventional
metaphysics there's so many different
styles and types of metaphysics out
there
Heidegger sees metaphysics in the way
that Aristotle does is the beat you know
study of being qua being he's bringing
new tools to the table
and he also thinks that we can talk
about
epochal metaphysics maybe this is what
you have in mind so there's different
there's different epochs in which
different fundamental ways of looking at
what being is changes and different ones
are dominant but Heidegger is definitely
not the only person to think that
thought egill thought that thought too
and so did some plenty of other people I
mean even even those who didn't formally
conceptualize it are you know still
getting at that that sort of phenomenon
tawny tiger their trends and philosophy
would appear that currently especially
in the USA existentialism was rather
derided is this the case not really
other question is dairy dup being taken
more seriously now no so those are easy
to answer
well that's C audio pervert what if
Adorno's the Frankfurt School s en masse
culture how it maps out or applies today
in a contemporary sense are you talking
about the culture industry I mean you
can that's the thing really maybe you
could go through it bit by bit and say
well this stuff still holds in this
stuff not so much that you're talking
about a book there right so how does it
apply in a contemporary sense if you
have to enter into the details with that
sort of thing Samuel says a girl is so
impressed with my knowledge of Hegel I
pull there bro thanks for half hour
Hegel well that's an unusual girl not
too many people male or female are
interested in Hegel so if you found
somebody who's a suitable romantic
partner through talking about Hegel
that's great I mean could have been a
fly-fishing you could have been your
share of cinnamon buns or coffee but
Hegel will do it then alright um just
skipped up a bit let's see if we got
here did you do wow there's a lot of
people weighing in I'm gonna get rid of
one of these people all right let's see
here get rid of General Lee let's see
where we were okay
EB one of my thoughts on Catherine
Malibu is usage of Hegel with
neuroscience and deconstruction Aven
rather my wife actually knows her but I
haven't gotten around reading her so
there's nothing I can say about that one
of my thoughts on logic and existence by
John if elites I like it believed quite
a bit as off as a Hegel commentator I
have not read logic in existence for a
long long time so again I don't have
anything to say about that Lyndon how
would I differentiate the material from
the non material does it need to become
more ethereal due to modern physics
I don't really thought much about that
in part because I'm willing to say that
physics doesn't tell us enough about the
material world that we encounter to
really like subsume it even physics plus
chemistry plus biology because although
this is material existence and yet
there's so much meaning packed in here
but I don't think it's just reducible to
like neurons fire
being ordered in certain ways I don't
know I don't I'd have to think about
that more
thus folk films if you could bring any
philosopher back to life to see how they
will impact and respond to our time
which one would it be
that's a good one I will often said that
you know I'd love to bring Aristotle to
my college classrooms and then you know
show him the fact that more than half of
my students are women and that they're
definitely not deficient when it comes
to the intellect by comparison to the
male students and then take him out to
the bar and say so I don't know did you
not have enough of a experiential basis
to avoid saying those boneheaded things
about women now maybe do you want to say
anything different about barbarians or
natural slaves or stuff like that
because you know
Aristotle being a good Aristotelian in
that respect had he had different you
know different experiences and the
ability to disentangle himself from the
culture that he was in he probably would
have seen stuff in a different manner so
that would be interesting it's so no
Baca reading through Khan's first
critique and having a bit of trouble
what later philosophers if any do you
feel have a firmer clarifying grasp on
it I don't know I mean I don't really
read a lot of later philosophers going
into great depth about Katz first
critique I just you know when I need to
read it cons first critique I read
Kant's first critique it is difficult
and we should expect it to be very
difficult so if you're only having a bit
of trouble actually you're way ahead of
the game there are some things in Conte
that I you know I've been reading him
for 25 years maybe longer
and there's still some things around
like what the hell is he talking about
here exactly you know even in the moral
philosophy which it's a lot easier than
the theoretical philosophy so
yeah all right let me see bozidar what
do I think of Spangler's work people
have asked me that before I think
Spengler is at best a third-rate
philosopher there seem to be people who
are quite into him and there always have
been I was never very impressed by what
I read but it's been a long time since I
read it some hello sir are you a stoic
no I am an eclectic I draw up on
stoicism as I do Aristotelian ISM and
Platonism which by the way doesn't just
mean Plato but means Plutarch and means
other later thinkers as well as I do
existentialism and I think that there's
a lot of useful things within stoicism
that said I probably know more about and
have probably practiced more actual
stoic principles and practices than many
of the johnny-come-lately people who
claim to be Stoics because they'd love
to have a camp to identify with but I
don't identify as a stoic although I am
of course the editor of stoicism today
Hannes and my cumulative oh my goodness
I had my cumulative Hegel final on
Tuesday wish me luck yeah good luck man
your videos are the only thing saving me
currently well that would be tough
humans of the cumulants of Hegel final I
don't know what they're gonna ask you
but there's so much stuff packed in
there that's that's quite difficult Sara
I'm looking for a short intro to history
of ideas any recommendations do you
think understanding that is valuable and
necessary for understanding literary
fiction or art so let's take the second
one first understanding the history of
ideas is it valuable for understanding
literary fiction are definitely valuable
is it necessary maybe not necessarily
necessary but but it certainly can help
you know for example you know I don't
know that much about art but I'll tell
you about one piece that I know quite a
bit
because I do some research on it this
summer from my existentialism class the
screen right Edward Munch's the scream
helps to know about Kierkegaard because
munch was as he tells us influenced by
Kierkegaard and the scream is not the
person screaming the scream is what
nature is doing and the person is
responding to it so knowing something
about Kierkegaard's discussions of the
individual and anxiety and all that
might also be cool to know that munch
later painted nietzsche so that's some
history of ideas stuff that's kind of
cool short intro to history of ideas I
don't know of any such thing as a matter
of fact any short intro is probably
garbage frankly because the history of
ideas is vast and and deep so any short
intro has probably got an agenda and is
gonna be distorting some things so all
right some some neuroscientists say that
the ego is an illusion and the sense of
I is actually just illusion and there is
no I why this findings don't change the
world isn't these findings extraordinary
you know it used to be that they'd say
there's no [ __ ] that some
philosopher won't eventually say right
and we could probably change that to
neuro scientists or evolutionary
biologists or any of the other popular
fields that you know people do work in
that have all sorts of you know wild
assumptions built into them and then get
reported on in the popular press so you
know I could be facetious and say did
that neuroscientist or probably
journalists because I'm guessing you
didn't read this from a neuroscience
Journal today actually like put their
name in the byline because if if so
they're being hypocritical oh but
there's there's no they to be
hypocritical right I mean some of this
stuff gets so absurd so quickly so what
if some neuroscientists say that the ego
is an illusion
maybe they're full of crap how do you
know that they're ant they're actually
getting it right why jump right in and
assume that because they have the term
neuroscientists that they're any better
off than the rest of us particularly
when there's like an entire literature
going way way back within not just
philosophy but religion and you know
literature itself about this very
problem I mean are these with these
findings be extraordinary within the
field of Buddhism it's been around I
don't know couple millennia not really
but you know again we you got to be
really careful with this this sort of
stuff who's actually saying it what does
their basis for saying it what
assumptions have they made what do they
mean by ego you see the same thing
coming up with free will oh they approve
free will doesn't exist whose version of
free will what what concept of free will
you know I am myself I'm usually very
skeptical about these these sorts of
claims all right cambric find myself
wondering when Aristotle would say about
a good friendship falling apart
reading Nicomachean ethics book 9 it
tells you all about it so you don't have
to wonder all right
I'm skipping over the stuff about
Dziedzic and Peterson because I've
talked about that ad nauseam I'm gonna
skip over the Noam Chomsky cuz I've
talked about that plenty of times as
well you know and I'm also gonna skip
over the rand stuff I've said it often
enough Rand is a philosopher a
third-rate philosopher Randy and is tend
to be pretty crazy people so is there
any merit in exploring your work sure as
much merit as there is important you
know exploring Spengler or I'd also say
Bertrand Russell's a third-rate
philosophers
but you know can't hurt to look at him
[Music]
Muhammad s what do I think about thomas
kuhn so he was somebody interesting who
he had to read when i was in grad school
the notion of paradigm shift is it's
useful it's difficult to explain exactly
how the shift takes place i think the
idea of paradigm shift got overblown
quite a bit as they moved it out of
philosophy of science and into other
areas but you know that's ok uremic
craft or what's the most popular view
about the external world held by
philosophers in contemporary philosophy
i wouldn't possibly know because I've
never done a poll of philosophers in
contemporary philosophy Watergate to
point would I recommend studying
philosopher philosophy without
philosophy classes it depends on your
situation if you can afford to take
philosophy classes then it certainly
wouldn't hurt to do so provided you get
a good professor and if you get a bad
professor in one place just go to
another place but can you study
philosophy without philosophy classes
sure I mean that's that's what a lot of
people have done and you know quite a
few of the philosophers who I work on
and study I never had a class on them
you know we know we never we read
Epictetus as enchiridion in in undergrad
but i never had a class on stoic
philosophy you just you know read the
stuff and read whatever secondary Lit
you want to and try putting it into
practice and you know everyone's around
bounce your ideas off of somebody else
and that's that's how you can learn you
know so alright um let's see bakwin is
critical theory philosophy are there any
major limitations to their lens Canon
explain everything so it depends on
who's critical theory you mean if you
mean by critical theory the Frankfurt
School yeah it's definitely for
they're philosophers mark whose Adorno
Horkheimer Habra mas those those types
right even erich fromm is a philosopher
as well as a psychoanalyst there's a
broader sense of critical theory in
which it doesn't just signify the
Frankfurt School and it's using a more
literary sense and it depends on what
you mean by philosophy in that case
there's no agreed-upon definition of
philosophy anyone who tries to tell you
that there is the full of crap and
they're pushing their own agenda on you
so you know is it philosophy yeah
although some of its actually quite bad
philosophy but there's a lot of bad
philosophy out there so I'm dual do I
think a move Road interesting philosophy
or is he someone overrated as a
philosopher I think he's underrated as a
philosopher because he's often presented
as if he wasn't a philosopher it was
just a literary figure who dabbled in
philosophy and that his philosophy isn't
very good you do have to get past his
style if you're reading things like myth
of sisyphus or there's later the rebel
I'd also put in there letters to a
German friend as really central so if
you're looking at that stuff you've got
to get past the style in which he frames
things but there's some real
philosophical depth there I'd say so
he's an undervalued thing EB what is my
thought on badiou to lose and Derrida I
don't read about you although again my
wife has studied with him I didn't I
don't read him not because I have an
objection to him I just haven't gotten
to his work Toulouse I find some of the
loses stuff quite interesting not as big
on the stuff that he does with Qatari
dairy - some of his stuff is interesting
whenever you read their their stuff you
always have to ask so this is pretty
cool is any of this actually true or is
it [ __ ]
you know but you have to do that with
everybody
Detra Derek Bowser Herr Dietrich von
Hildebrand is being considered to be
made a doctor of the church is that
warranted in your opinion I don't know
he's a great philosopher I can tell you
that but I don't know who should be a
doctor if the church you know um all
right Jane tunic and then I read
anything from Maximus the Confessor
thoughts on his philosophy and theology
yeah I read I read Maximus he you know I
mostly look at him when I'm when I'm
looking at stuff about how concepts from
Greek philosophy are getting brought
further into time I've never done like a
systematic study of his work so all
right audio pervert what do I make of
Jacques Derrida's font ology it does
play out in electronic music today synth
way of being example I'm to take your
your word for that I have no idea what
since we've you even as I don't listen
to electronic music so I suspect that
there probably Derry does complex and
difficult to read and make sense of so I
that it's they're probably taking some
of this stuff and cutting out little
bits and then using that and distorting
it the way that usually happens whenever
anybody moves philosophy into pop
culture areas but I don't know I could
be completely wrong so all right let's
see what else we've we've got Elizabeth
just came by to say thank you for your
knowledge you helped me in my philosophy
class you're very welcome glad it was
helpful for you
Tomic who's had his reference work
across possible worlds I don't know you
got to pick which possible world
semantics you want you'll probably find
that in david lewis it's been a long
time since i looked at that
so Michael New Year McIntyre says virtue
ethics must be examined in context of a
tradition how is this
a form of relativism so there's an
entire literature out there about that
MacIntyre actually addresses some of
that stuff and if I remember right in
the preface to a third edition of after
virtue so you can read read that stuff
but why would you jump from being
understood in a tradition of relativism
they're not the same thing saying that
that you need to have some sort of basis
in order to understand something and
that that basis would would not be
something that all humans would
automatically have that's not the same
thing as relativism relativism is a much
stronger sort of claim saying there is
no there is no truth you know across
traditions or anything like that
MacIntyre again MacIntyre deals with
this stuff so I would just I would
reread after virtue let's see here
I'm gonna start skipping through stuff
to pick things that are easy to address
or there's a lot of fever benefit sir
Russell said Hegel's all ideas are false
why I don't know that he said they're
all false that that doesn't sound like
Russell to me because that would be
insane to say that somebody's all of
somebody's ideas are false that wouldn't
even make sense
and we're gonna skip down a bit more to
find Wow here's a good question John
Ortiz what are the fundamental skills of
philosophy and so there's many but I'll
talk about one in particular one of the
skills that you absolutely cannot do
without in philosophy is making good
distinctions at the right time when
people come out with these blanket
statements of X is why you gotta say
well some X is why sure and depends on
what you mean by Y because we want to be
totally clear about things I'm not going
to jump onto your X's wide bandwagon
just because you need a lot of you know
likes or something like that let's it's
carefully considered what are the
different X's you're talking about what
are the different Y's and I'll tell you
that when it comes to like the work that
I do particularly with businesses but
also with other academics you know like
arthur c clarke said that to the to the
you know the primitive or the savage
technology appears to be a kind of magic
it's like that with philosophy and
making distinctions if you can make
distinctions well it seems like magic to
people who cannot do that who don't
don't have that skill they're like holy
crap how did you how did you know that
you're like you know this is a something
that we've covered in this or this or
this so all right
a lot of people
getting the same question over and over
again I'm not sure why they're doing
that like they think that I'll more
likely answer it if it's been asked
multiple times when it's actually the
opposite here's another good one from
Boleyn cent how do I deal with trolls on
the internet I ban them and block them
very very quickly and as a matter of
fact I probably have a net that's that's
airing on the side of banning people who
aren't really trolls but since my time
is limited and since I look at my social
media and my videos is sort of like
being my front porch there's stuff that
I'm put it as content like I'm putting
out there and other people can benefit
from if they want to if somebody wants
to give me a hard time I'm gonna kick
him out and so that's that's what I you
know for a while I kind of wavered and I
was like oh I should you know I should
be more charitable and forgiving and
then I realized you know I got maybe 40
good years left if that I'm not gonna
dick around you know wasting it on
people who want to be tendentious or
just want to troll or waste my time my
time is valuable probably you're all of
your time is valuable too and that's the
way that we should treat people who
waste our time you throw them out you
don't give them a chance you know and
I've had a few people where they'd like
contacted me afterwards and apologized
and you know I've like let them back in
you know because we're talking about
like Facebook Twitter YouTube other
other modes sometimes LinkedIn I've had
to block people on LinkedIn as well so
yeah
all right um so that was a good question
let's see here Andre how do you read
Bakhtin's carnivalesque Boris gross or
just black teen wrote it in response and
as a mirror to Stalin's purges well
that's an interesting thing
I haven't read Grace's anti philosophy
and I imagine it's probably coming from
there
so Bakhtin's carnival ask is talking
about coming from the Rob Lai book but
it shows up in a few other places as
well it says that like the the the mode
of the carnival is when like everything
is switched and order has been subverted
and and that we do this every once in a
while it's not it's not a radically new
idea
nature's idea the DNS scene is similar
there's other people who talked about
this this this process as well
does it mate does it make sense to see
it in terms of Stalinism I guess why in
mierda Stalinist purges because of the
the forced participation in the
political I mean one of the things with
Bakhtin is the political order in the
carnival breaks down right it becomes
verted so a mirror to Stalinist purges a
reversal of that I guess that could make
sense yeah here we go Andrew was
Heidegger an atheist did he believe in a
personal God I don't think you can say
that he believed in a personal God was
he an atheist depends on what kind of
atheist you mean I guess you could say
he was an atheist in the way that
Nietzsche was an atheist the kind of
person who would look at like most of
the New Atheism today and say wow you're
just as much theological as the
Christians who you're attacking I mean
he's got the thing only a God can save
us but people have made different things
about that
all right let's see what else we've got
here just jump to bits
leopoldo asks do I think philosophy
would make us less fragile depends on
whose philosophy and how we're doing it
I mean there are some pretty fragile
Plato's scholars out there that I've met
but Plato read properly and applied
properly should make us less so it
really depends on how you're you know
the approach that you're taking to
philosophy and whether you're like
turning it into a kind of a game that we
play with each other or you know what we
what we do it
Crossley's em Baca will we ever get a
video on Hegel's lectures on the
philosophy of history well you'll never
get a video on anything that's that's a
big work because I don't try to
summarize big works in a single video
because that's bad doing bad philosophy
doing bad history of ideas right I like
I said earlier I shoot mainly at this
point in time as supplements to my
classes for my students not teaching
Hegel's philosophy lectures on the
philosophy of history in my classes and
I'm pretty busy with the half-hour Hegel
project when I actually get to it so you
know you might think about supporting
the half-hour Hegel project and getting
that done and then afterwards we can
talk about whether more Hegel stuff
should be done but if you want to
commissioned me to shoot videos on it
you certainly can people have done that
with other things in the past with
Nietzsche and Heidegger so all right um
let me see if I can find a nice one to
go out on because we're almost dead an
hour and a half a lot of people are
asking me about things I don't have any
idea about here's a good one very
quickly Matt Myers why do we think why
do I think Anselm's philosophy is
superior to Aquinas is I don't I don't
think either superior to either there's
plenty of Thomas that think that Thomas
is superior to everybody so I provide
you know I'm more interested in Anselm
than I am Aquinas but that's good enough
[Music]
here's a good one fado remains when
reading Kierkegaard you think the
pseudonyms he wrote under change how we
should read him in other words are these
supposed to be Kierkegaard thoughts or
the student pseudonym as writers
thoughts well they're both and should it
change how we read him sometimes but
there's no it's not like it's not like
we can always say you know here's
Kierkegaard and then here's the
pseudonyms and we should treat all the
pseudonyms this way you got to do it on
a case-by-case basis and for anybody who
wants to make the strong claim that we
absolutely can't read you know this
person is being cared to guard well they
better say it and you know for the rest
of us then precisely what we're supposed
to be reading in there because I find a
lot of this to be rather obscure in
tests and you know way of trying to be
like one upping other people so let's
see a lot of
stuff in here well here's a good one to
go out on especially this time of the
year
did I ever struggle with academic
deadlines as a student how do you deal
with students facing such issues if
they're just having trouble meeting
academic deadlines and they don't have
some good reason for that like you know
medical issue or like I have a student
who's getting surgery this this semester
at the end of the semester because
that's when they scheduled it then there
as we say [ __ ] out of luck
you know they won't get the the grades
for the stuff that they they've they've
got if it's some legitimate reason then
I give them an incomplete and they get
their work done when they they can't you
know I let students turn in work late
with a penalty throughout the entire
semester very forgiving when it comes to
that sort of thing I did I have trouble
with that no not so much
I've had more trouble later on as a
professor getting stuff done on time
right just because I've always got so
much work to do but as a student I
didn't have too much trouble meeting my
academic deadlines I'd usually get stuff
done ahead of time but you know I
understand that those sort of things
happen I think the biggest thing to keep
in mind is that a lot of students get
very obsessed about their grades and
grades are not as important as people
make them out to be most employers are
not going to care about what your GPA is
and you could say well this is going to
keep me from getting into graduate
school you know if a bad grade on in an
assignment is what's going to keep you
out of getting into graduate school it's
not that grade that's keeping you out
it's the whole string of other bad
grades that this one is like you know
that the straw that broke the proverbial
camel's back you're already doing well
you can take a couple big hits
academically speaking if you're not
that's because you've already got a
of not turning stuff in when when you
should and not doing things the way that
you you ought to be doing and then and
then it's a more like learning time
management or deciding whether you
really want to do this this course of
studies so that's probably a good thing
to go out on I think this is probably
the last I mean I might do some some
philosophy pop-ups over the Christmas
season once all my grades are in I've
got so much work to do now the rest of
this weekend so we'll see how it we'll
see how that goes but well yeah I might
do some some other pop ups so those
would be other streaming things as well
but otherwise hope everybody has a great
holiday season and those who are in town
maybe I'll see you at some of our
face-to-face events or in some of the
other online events and that's it from
here